when President Trump was mocked by
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
this week at the NATO meeting of course
our press ate it up see we're not
respected in the world they were
essentially laughing at the u.s.
President there that's remarkable
imagine getting laughed off an entire
continent this is how they talk about
our president when people are laughing
at you that means you're the joke he's
the brunt of a joke right there which is
gonna be haunting this president right
through at least Saturday Night Live
this week yes wrong wrong wrong
I wonder if Justin is still laughing
we're covering this breaking news of the
Canadian economy shedding more than
70,000 jobs in the month of November
this is the largest jump in the
unemployment rate by the way when you
look at sort of monthly performance
since 2009 oh it's not doing so well
there in Canada we want you to do better
but and remember French president
Emmanuel macron was also there giggling
alongside Trudeau but perhaps he should
have been taking care of business at
home the the economic situation Frances
is unsustainable you have unemployment
at nearly 9% huge unfunded pension
liabilities this is absolutely
unsustainable
of course British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson he hosted the NATO soiree and
was also having a good time too bad the
same cannot be said for his own middle
class the UK economy is in the worst
shape since 2010
and things aren't any better in Italy
here's yesterday's headline Italy's
economic growth set to remain weak in
near-term oh but Germany is doing better
right well here's what things look like
their German orders resumed slide define
hope for a factory rebound so maybe
that's why I Angela Merkel always looks
like she's sat on a pine cone especially
when she's next to Trump as for Japan
well things aren't any better there
Japan's economic troubles offer a
glimpse of a sobering future I'm showing
you all of this because every day
American workers should think the bank
good lord that we have a president who
actually gets it we have a tight labor
market that means wages are going up we
have more deregulation that frees up
businesses to grow and hire gives them a
lot of incentives we have lower taxes
that means you keep more of your own
money to spend it as you see fit the
Democrats they just don't trust your
judgment they want more control over
almost every major decision you make
they're also of course trying to impeach
a president on nothing I'm nothing phone
call hearsay conjecture during one of
our greatest economies in the past half
century 266 thousand jobs in November
this blows away expectations we don't
take any Glee in this at all it's
heartbreaking but the President and it
gave us no choice this is the best
number I've ever seen in my life you
can't contradict it these are the best
numbers of our lives I speak for my
colleagues when I say that I do that we
do not take this lightly report everyone
should be thrilled with the great jobs
number has let this market go from
shrugs to hugs we do not intend to delay
when the integrity of the next election
is still at risk this is a good number
for re-election
well you see the this dissonance here
amazing economic news and glum morose
horrified Democrats they want to impeach
this economy
I'm glad the White House dismissed
Democrats 5:00 p.m. deadline for
cooperating on impeachment today why do
I find it hard to take I don't know
Pelosi Nadler shift seriously because
they're fundamentally unserious people
Bloomberg gave it all up yesterday in an
interview they know they can't win with
Biden in the gang that's why he jumped
in their entire 2020 campaign strategy
consists of one word impeachment they're
just not serious about working on
important issues that could actually
improve your life not us MCA
not prescription drugs not
infrastructure despite Pelosi's claims
to the contrary we have 275 bills mr.
Seki legislate investigate litigate she
should have added regurgitate okay it's
the same thing over and over again it's
a farce in 2018 moderate Democrats
campaigned on this idea that they would
work with the President on key issues
but they've only worked to oust him they
should all be tossed out none of the
twenty twenty Democrats argue that they
can do a better job on the economy they
can't they don't even really try anymore
when they're not pushing a totally
baseless impeachment they're catering to
groups like Planned Parenthood the NEA
care and of course the EU and they you
by the way loves them because the EU can
play them this has been a phenomenal
week for the President and for the
country
he was derided by the elites on the
international stage and by academics on
the domestic stage and he ended it with
a Socko economic report that is the envy
of the world the Democrats aren't mad
because President Trump's policies
aren't working they're seething because
they are and how sad for them and their
car
we'll act of a party but for the rest of
us we're gonna keep working hard and
playing hard we're gonna be counting our
blessings and staying focused on what
really matters especially this time of
year Faith Family and our country
and that's the angle